- [Interviewer] All right, Steven,
Steven, where you from
originally, where'd you grow up?
(indistinct)
- [Interviewer] Where?
- [Steven] Englewood.
- [Interviewer] Englewood.
- [Steven] Near the hospital.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
you grew up with both of your parents?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- Well, it was kinda messed up.
- [Interviewer] Kinda messed up?
- Yeah, I seem to had a half older sister,
a half a year older than me.
And wow, what the fuck?
She didn't have the same
blood type as my parents,
and it seems like my parents were--.
My mother kicked out my
father before I was born.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- My mother kicked out my
father before I was born.
And I hate to say this, my
older sister, who like hated me.
- [Interviewer] Your sister hated you?
- Yeah, well she had a whack blood type
and my mother thought she,
she's on some redhead thing,
a narrative, they said
it's a rare blood type,
that certainly couldn't
have come from my family.
It was like an exotic
blood type, and they--.
I always didn't see how
she was my half sister, so.
Oh, in 1968, apparently a nurse told her.
Well, actually 1968--.
- [Interviewer] Steven, what age
were you when you left your parents house?
- Oh, anyway, she was,
my oldest, my parents,
my mother cheated on my
father before I was born.
And this older sister, she was
born with a rare blood type.
And all my family (indistinct).
- [Interviewer] Steven, what is your drug?
- LSD.
- [Interviewer] LSD?
- Mhmm.
- [Interviewer] And how long
have you been using LSD?
- I have this amazing thing
with psychedelic drugs.
I was in Maryland, of all places.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you been using LSD?
- [Steven] Oh, excuse my (indistinct).
I thought my mother had taken LSD
and I said whack that shit.
And I told her about it, I had this.
- [Interviewer] How
often do you use LSD now?
- [Steven] Five, uh anyway.
I had this, I have to say this.
In Maryland I had excess
whacked from using drugs,
and I was so fucking
twisted, I was, I was,
well I thought I was fucking hallucinating
from twisted plastic,
excuse my frickin' mother had taken LSD
when I was born, what the fuck was that?
And apparently--.
- [Interviewer] Steven,
when did you first try LSD,
how old were you?
- Actual, about seven.
- [Interviewer] Seven?
- Around there.
- [Interviewer] You think
you were seven years old
when you tried it?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Who gave
you LSD at seven years old?
- When I was in, oh when
did I first start LSD?
- [Interviewer] When
did you first try LSD?
You told me seven, I'm not
sure that's an accurate.
- Oh, I was probably in
Maryland I had this whack gene,
twisted shit, my gene,
I asked my mother if
she took LSD and stuff
and she said she never did.
And whatever, it seemed to have--.
- [Interviewer] Steve, do you
find LSD here on Skid Row?
You can purchase it here?
- [Steven] No, actually cocaine,
but anyway (indistinct).
(indistinct)
Well I had a whack older
sister that wasn't mine.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, we talked
about your sister before.
Steve, do you have kids of your own?
Do you have children?
- Oh, I have a sister anyways,
sorry I can't seem to--.
(indistinct) But there,
oh my older sister,
she had a whack blood type,
and my half older sister
and for the life of me,
we were running around 1969, or similar.
- [Interviewer] We're done.
- [Steven] Rare blood type that could
not come from her genetics.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Steve, Steve, Steve.
Thank you for talking to me, excellent.
Thank you very much.